สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะกลับมาเจอกับครูฟ้าและครู
เรียมในวดีโอ beginner  4 นะคะ beginner
4  comprehensible ไทยเนาะช่อง
comprehensible ไยยใช่ค่ะแล้ววันนี้ที่
เราคุยกันอยู่ตอนนี้วันอะไรคะครู
ฟ้าวันพุธ
ค่ะวันพุธวันที่เท่าไหร่ค่ะวันที่
9 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤศจิกายนอืปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 แล้วปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะ
โอเคตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะคุณฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา
น 36 น
อืครูฟ้าครูฟ้าเล่าเรื่องพิคเคิล
แล้วจบแล้วค่ะครูฟ้ากำลังจะออกไปซื้อ
ตุ๊กตาใช่ไหมยใช่ค่ะครูเรียมถ้านักเรียน
อยากรู้ว่าเรื่องพินอคคิโอเป็นยังไงก็
วดีโอนะคะนักเรียนลองเสิร์ชดูวิดีโอ
พินอคคิโอครูฟ้าเล่าไปแล้วนะคะตอนนี้
เนี่ยครูฟ้าก็เลยจะไปซื้อ
ตุ๊กตาตุ๊กตาพินอคคิโออืมฟ้ากำลังจะออกไป
ข้างนอกค่ะครูเหี่ยมเรียมก็เลยถามครูฟ้า
ว่าครูฟ้าจะออกไปข้างนอกยังไง
อืมคิดว่าน่าจะขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ไปได้มย
ออขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ไปก็ดีนะเพราะว่าถ้าครู
ฟ้ามีมอเตอร์ไซค์เป็นของตัวเองอืก็ไม่
ต้อง
รอใช้เวลารอ
เอ๊มีรถขับผ่านมาหรือเปล่า
ออถ้าครูฟ้าไม่มีมอเตอร์ไซค์ครูฟ้าต้องรอ
รถหรอคะครูเรี่ยมใช่ค่ะ
ถ้าถ้าห้างอยู่ไกลมากๆอ
อะไรก็ต้องรอรถอ๋อรอรถแท็กซี่รอรถแบรอรถ
ใชปู้รอรถโอมีหลายรถออนี่รถหรออใช่อันนี้
รถ 2 แถวนะคะใช่อันนี้รถ 2 แถวรถ 2 แถว
พัทยามีเยอะอืใช่นี่แหละรูฟ้าก็ต้องรอรถ
รถ 2 แถวขับผ่านมารูฟ้าก็จะจอดค่ะจอด
อืจอดหน่อยค่ะอันนี้โบกรถนะคะนักเรียนโบก
รถเวลาที่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยเอ่อจะขึ้นรถ 2 แถว
อาจจะต้องโบกรถหรือว่ารถแท็กซี่ก็โบกรถ
ใช่มยนักเรียนก็จะมีการโบกรถนะคะเราต้อง
โบกรถอืใช่หลายๆคนที่ไม่มีรถยนต์ไม่มีรถ
มอเตอร์ไซค์
อก็จะนั่งรถ 2 แถวใชแอวค่ะครูเมเอ้านั่ง
รถไม่ดียังไงอ่ะก็โอเคมครูฟ้าไม่ค่อยนั่ง
รถไง 2 แถวอ่ะอูเรียมเพราะว่าถ้าเกิดครู
ฟ้าไปห้างใช่มยไป Terminal  21 อืแล้วครู
ฟ้าตกรถอ่ะถ้าครูฟ้ามีสอนนักเรียนครูครู
ฟ้าก็จะกลับมาที่ห้องไม่ทันอืเหมือนครู
ฟ้ามีสอนตอน 15  15 นค่ะออใช่ถ้าครูฟ้าตก
รถครูฟ้าก็จะมาสอนไม่
ทัน
ใช่ตกรถยังไงอ่ะครู
เลียมตกรถมี 2 ความหมายนะครููฟ้าตกรถมี 2
ความหมายเลยเหรอคะใช่โอ
ตกแบบที่ 1 ตกแล้วก็เจ็บโอ้
เจ็บตกรถสมมุติว่าครูฟ้าอันนี้เป็นรถใช่
มั้แล้วครูฟ้ากำลังจะขึ้นรถแล้วครูฟ้าก็
ตกใช่เหมือนอยู่ในรูปเลยแสนูขอวาดรูปได้ม
เออาได้ได้ครูเรียมมีรูปให้ดูนะคะแต่ว่า
ครูฟ้าจะวาดรูปูฟ้าตกรถอะไรได้บ้าง
มอเตอร์ไซค์ก็ตกได้นะคะนักเรียนได้ใช่ไหม
อย่างที่อันนี้เป็นรถนะ
คะรถอะไรคะเนี่ยอ๋ออันนี้เป็นประตูเมื่อ
กี้ครูฟ้าวาดมายาวๆเดมก็คิดว่าอ้าครูฟ้า
วาดลิมูซีนรือเปล่าลิมูซีน
อุยไม่มีเงินนะคะลิมูซีนมันจะแพงเกินไป
แล้วครูฟ้ากำลังจะขึ้นรถใช่
ไห
อืแล้วครูฟ้าก็ตกรถโอ๊ยอ้าแล้วไปเอาขามา
ด้วยขาเอาขาด้วยค่ะครูป๊าได้ค่ะเอาขามา
ด้วยนะ
คะอะไรกันคะเนี่ยเทำอะไรนะคะเจะให้ดูว่า
ตกรถเป็นยังไงไงวาดใหม่ดีกว่าก็ถ้าครูฟ้า
เนี่ยกำลังจะขึ้นรถใช่ไหมแล้วตกรถขึ้นยัง
ไงให้ตกรถนะะวก็จะอยู่ที่
นี่โอ๊ยครูพ้าก็จะโอ๊ยโอ๊ย
มย
โอ๊ยกำลังจะขึ้นรถแล้วก็ตกรถรถอาจจะแบบืน
ไปข้างหน้าแล้วูฟ้ากำลังขึ้นกขึ้นรถก็แบบ
วืนแล้วครูฟ้าก็ตก
รถเจ็บนะคะนักเรียนตกรถอันเนี้ยใช่เจ็บอื
เหมือนอันนี้เลยคนนี้ก็แบบขึ้นรถไปแล้ว
แต่ว่ามีคนในรถเยอะมากๆอืเค้าก็เลยแบบ
โอ๊ถ้าตกลงมานะตกลงมาตรงเนี้ยก็แบบโอ๊ย
เจ็บ
เจ็บใช่แต่มีตกรถอีกแบบนึงนะที่ไม่เจ็บ
อ้าวแล้วตกรถอีกแบบนึงที่ไม่เจ็บเป็นยัง
ไงคะครูเหรียมที่ไม่เจ็บก็คือเหมือนในรูป
เนี้ยเป็นรถอะไรคะครููฟ้ารถบัสมะเอ้ย
รถบัสมยรถบัสรถไฟรถเมล์ัสรถเมล์เออรถเม์
หรือเปล่าใช่รเม์เหมือนครูฟ้าสมมุติว่า
เราไม่มีรถมอเตอร์ไซค์ไม่มีรถยนต์เราก็
ต้องไปรอใช้เวลา
รอรถบัสรอรถเมล์อค่ะเพราะว่ารถเมล์จะมา
ถึงตอน
ประมาณ 7:00
น
อื 7 นครูฟ้าก็ต้องครูฟ้าก็ต้องมาตอน
18:30 น
มย
ได้ถึงจะไม่ตกรถใช่แต่บางคนก็มาตอน 7 น 3
นอ้า 73 นโอเคมั้ยคะครูเรียม 73 นบาง
ครั้งก็ตกรถ
อ๋อตกรถก็
คือรถไปแล้วใช่รถไปตอน 7:00 นอืแต่ว่าคน
เนี่ยคนคนหลายๆคนมาประมาณ
นทำยังไงล่ะครูฟ้าวิ่งมารถอืรถไปแล้วนะคะ
ครูฟ้าพิ่งมาครูฟ้าตกรถใช่แล้วครูฟ้าจะไป
ออฟฟิศยังไงครูฟ้าก็อาจจะโบกวิน
มอเตอร์ไซค์โบก
แท็กซี่โบกแท็กซี่นะคะครูพ้าอาจจะต้อง
เรียกรถโบกรถโบกแท็กซี่แล้วก็นั่งไปแต่
โบกแท็กซี่ไปมันจะแพงอ่ะครูเลี่มหรือว่า
ครูฟ้าจะรอรอจะมีรถเมล์มา
อีกตอนประมาณ 8:00 น
อืได้มั้ยครู
ฟ้าครูฟ้าจะสายมั้ยคะฟ้าจะไปออฟฟิศสายบอส
ก็จะบอกว่าทำไมมาออฟฟิศสายอืมครูฟ้าก็จะ
บอก
ว่าครูฟ้าตกรถค่ะอ๋อตกรถเตกรถบสครูฟ้าจะ
พูดว่านี่ไงตื่นสายยตื่นซ้ายก็เลยตกรถใช่
โอ้โหไม่นะอืไม่ใช่แค่รถอย่างเดียวนะคะ
ครูฟ้าที่ตกแบบนี้ตกแบบไม่เจ็บนะแต่ว่าทำ
ให้เราใช้เวลามากขึ้นแล้วตกอะไรได้อีกคะ
ครูเรียมมี
ตกเครื่องตกเครื่องบิน
คามว่าอันนี้นักเรียนน่าจะเคยเป็นมยน่าจะ
เคยเป็นหรือเปล่าคะน่าจะไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่แบบ
ที่เออมันก็มี 2 ความหมายเนาะใช่ค่ะเพราะ
ว่าเวลาขึ้นเครื่องบินเราต้องเดินขึ้น
บันไดใช่มยอันนี้เป็นเครื่องบินแล้วก็จะ
มีบันไดเราก็ต้องเดินถ้าครูฟ้าเดินแล้ว
ครูฟ้าก็โอ๊ะสะดุดตกเครื่องบิน
เจ็บใช่เหมือนกันนะคะแต่ว่าน่าจะเป็น 0
จุด 0000  1% นะคูบา 1% ค่ะเพราะว่าเดิน
ยังไงให้ตกคะไม่ได้หรอกอืนั่นแหละแล้วก็
ตกเครื่องบินอีกอย่างนึงก็คือเหมือนตกรถ
ใช่มยใช่ที่แบบมีมีตั๋วแล้วตั๋วเครื่อง
บินมีพาสปอร์ตอืแล้วเครื่องบินน่ะเครื่อง
บินจะขึ้นตอน 8:00 นอื
อืแต่ว่าเค้าลืมลืมพาสปอร์ตครูฟ้า
โด้ทำยังไงคะลืมพาสปอร์ตลืมพาสปอร์ตไว้
ที่
บ้านไม่ได้ค่ะครูเรียมลืมพาสปอร์ตก็ต้อง
ขับรถกลับไปเอาพาสปอร์ตที่บ้านก่อนใช่ก็
ขับรถขับรถเร็วมาก
ู้อืแต่พอกลับมานะก็เป็น
เวลา
น 85 นมันเลทมากเลย
รียมเครื่องบินจะรอเรามั้ยคะไม่รอ
ค่ะเครื่องบินไม่รอหรอทำไมแบบนี้ครูฟ้าก็
ตกเครื่องบินสิเครื่องบินเนี่ยเท Off
แล้วนะคะครูฟ้าอยู่นี่เครื่องบินก็เท Off
ไปแล้วครูฟ้าตกเครื่อง
บินใช่
[เพลง]
แล้วไม่นะอ้าจริงๆครูฟ้าก็เคยตกมั้ย
เครื่องบินไม่เคยค่ะเพราะว่าครูฟ้าเคย
ขึ้นเครื่องบินแค่ 1 ครั้งเท่านั้นนะคะก็
เลยไม่เคยตกเครื่องบิน
อืยังไม่เคยตกเครื่องบินค่ะแสดงว่าครูฟ้า
ก็ใช้รถอย่าง
อื่นใช่จะ
เป็นรถรถ 2 แถวที่พัทยาเนาะอืมรถ 2 แถว
อืมแต่ว่าครูฟ้าก็มีมอเตอร์ไซค์เนาะก็มี
มอเตอร์ไซค์ไม่ต้องนั่งรถ 2 แถวใช่ว่าเคย
นั่งรถ 2 แถวนะคะแล้วก็
เอิ่มเคยตกรถในความหมายที่ 2 มั้งคือครู
ฟ้ามาเทแล้วรถก็ออกไปแล้วแล้วครูฟ้าก็ตก
รถฟ้าก็เลยต้องหารถคันใหม่ขึ้นอะไรอย่าง
งั้นนะคะแต่ตกรถความหมายที่ 1 แบบเดิน
แล้วตกอันนี้ครูพฟไม่เคยนะคะไม่เคยคิดว่า
ในกรุงเทพฯนักเรียนต้องระวังถ้านักเรียน
อยู่ไทยใช่ไหมแล้วนักเรียนเนี่ยอยู่
กรุงเทพฯนะคะแล้วนักเรียนต้องใช้รถ
เมล์อืมรถเมล์เอิ่มแบบนี้เนาะเดี๋ยวริม
เอารถเมล์แบบ
นี้ใช่รถเมล์อย่างเงี้ยนักเรียนต้องระวัง
นะคะเพราะว่ารถเมล์เนี่ยเวลาขับมาใช่มวืน
เอี๊ยดเบรคแล้วนักเรียนกำลังจะ
ขึ้นบางทีรถเมล์ก็จะแบบออกเค้าเรียกว่า
อะไรขับออกไปเลยอ่ะเออันที่แบบรื้นออกไป
แล้วนักเรียนกำลังขึ้นนักเรียนอาจจะจะตก
รถก็ได้นะคะอันนี้ต้องระวังรถเมล์ใน
กรุงเทพฯอืใช่ๆค่ะแล้วก็นอกจากรถ
เมล์ตกรถเมล์ตกเครื่องบินแล้วก็ยังมีรถไฟ
นะคะตกรถไฟได้ด้วยหรอคะใช่ค่ะเพราะว่า
เวลาที่เราจะแบบอาจจะเป็นซื้อตั๋วซื้อ
ตั๋วในเว็บไซต์อืซื้อตวในเว็บไซต์ว่าออรถ
ไฟจะออก
ประมาณ 9:00 น
ออใช่ก็ซื้อตั๋วเรียบร้อยแล้วอืๆๆแต่พอ
ออกจากบ้านก็แบบตื่นมาได้ยินเสียงติ๊ดๆๆๆ
ๆๆๆๆๆก็แบบไม่ตื่นค่ะนอนไม่ตื่นนอนต่อ
เหรอคะใช่แล้วพอตื่นขึ้นมาก็ดูโทรศัพท์อ
้อ 8:00 น 8
นต้องรีบๆๆๆไปโบกแท็กซี่
หืนี่ไงใช่จะไปสถานีรถไฟอืัวไม่เคยขึ้นรถ
ไฟเลยนะตกรถไฟอใช่เหมือนกันนะคะแล้วถ้าตก
รถไฟต้องทำยังไงคูเรียม
ตกรถไฟก็ต้องซื้อตั๋วใหม่
อืใช่เราอาจจะซื้อไว้ตอน 99:00 นค่ะแต่มา
ถึงตอนประมาณ 9:30 น
หืก็ต้องซื้อตั๋วอีกใบนึงใช่ซื้อตัวอกนึง
อจะเป็นเวลา 10:00 นก็ได้ค่ะออเห็นมยนี่
คือตกรถ
ไงอืใช่แต่ว่าถ้าเป็นตกรถไฟฟ้า BTS ล่ะ
ค่ะตกรถไฟฟ้า
BTS ต้องซื้อตั๋วใหม่มั้ยครูฟ้าไม่ต้อง
ค่ะถ้าเป็นรถไฟฟ้า BTS  MRT นะคะนักเรียน
นักเรียนก็ซื้อตั๋วแล้วนักเรียนก็มายืน
รอไม่มีเวลานะรถก็จะมาแล้วนักเรียนก็ขึ้น
ถ้านักเรียนขึ้นรถไฟฟ้า BTS คันนี้ไม่
ทันรถออกไปแล้วนักเรียนก็ยืนรอยืนรอยืนรอ
แล้วก็จะมีรถ BTS มาใหม่นะคะไม่ต้องซื้อ
ตั๋วใหม่อื
อืใช่แล้วก็เตรียมเห็น
ว่าต๋ว
BTS จะเป็นแบบการ์ดเหมือนการ์ดเนาะอืใช่
ๆเป็นแบบการ์ดก็มีนะคะนักเรียนนเรียนก็
ยืนรอได้เลยซื้อตั๋วแล้วก็ยืนรอ
ใช่แล้วรถไฟฟ้าใต้ดินล่ะคะคุณูฟ้าตกได้ม
ไฟฟ้าใต้ดินหรือ MRT ก็เหมือนกันค่ะ
เหมือน BTS เลยนะคะไม่ตกรถอืมไม่ตกรถนะ
อันนี้
MRT ใช่แต่ว่าถ้าเกิดถ้าเกิดอันเนี้ยคือ
รอบ 8  8 น
เออกไปแล้ว
ฟิ้วเรามาแล้วก็อุ๊ยวันนี้จะไปทำงานจะไป
ทำงานแต่ว่าถ้ารอประมาณ 6 นาที 7 นาทีใช่
อาจจะตกรอบ 8:00 นอาจจะรอรอบอ 86 นอืใช่
แต่ว่าก็ไปทำงาน
สายนิดหน่อยนะคะนิด
หน่อยใช่ๆอือือเห็นมก็เลยแบบอยากถามนัก
เรียนเหมือนกันว่านักเรียนเคยตกอะไร
มั้ยตกรถตกเรือตกเครื่อง
บินตกมั้ยคะอืมอาจจะตกนะแต่เรา 2 คนไม่
ได้พูดแล้วหมายถึงตกลงมาแล้วเจ็บนะแบบ
โอ๊ยแบบเนี้ยไม่ใช่นะไม่ใช่ค่ะไม่ใช่
เพราะว่านักเรียนบางคนอาจจะเคยตกรถแบบแบบ
ที่ 1 ใช่มั้ยแบบแบบที่ 1 โอ๊ยเจ็บั้นไป
โรงพยาบาลนะคะนักเรียนพี่พอพี่ปอก็ตกรถ
แบบที่ 1 บางคนก็อาจจะเคยอ่าหรือบางคนก็
อาจจะเคยตกรถแบบที่
2 ก็คือมาเลทนะคะรถออกไปแล้วบ๊ายบายเรา
เพิ่งมาอืใช่แต่ตกรถแบบที่ 2 เนี่ยอาจจะ
แบบไม่ได้เจ็บ
แล้ว
ก็มีแบบที่ต้องจ่ายเงินมากขึ้นแล้วก็อาจ
จะเป็นแบบไม่ได้จ่ายเงินมากขึ้นแต่ก็ใช้
เวลามากขึ้น
อืเห็นมนี่แหละแล้วแต่แต่ครูฟ้าดีมากครู
ฟ้าไม่เคยตกรถแบบที่แบบไปเรทไปสายอืไม่
เคยค่ะเคยครั้งเดียวมั้งรถอะไรที่ครูฟ้า
พูดไปเมื่อกี้นะคะแต่ว่าครูฟ้าก็ไม่เคยตก
รถเออไม่เคยตกเครื่องบินไม่เคยตกเรือนะคะ
อืครูฟ้าไปมีเวลาใช่มยถ้ารถออก 8:00 นครู
ฟ้าก็จะไป
730 นก็มีเวลา
อืยิ่งแบบถ้าเป็นเครื่องบินนะถ้าเป็น
เครื่องบินก็ยิ่งใช้เวลานานที่แบบต้องไป
รอใช่มยครูฟ้าใช่ต้องรอ 1 ชมงนะอืแล้ว
เครื่องบินเนี่ยก็ราคาแพงด้วยนะคะตก
เครื่องบินไม่โอเคนะคะใช่เออซื้อซื้อตั๋ว
เท่าไหร่นะซื้อตั๋ว 1,000 บาท 1,000 บาท
ตกเครื่องบินแล้วก็ต้องแบบซื้อตั๋วอีก
1,000 บาทอืมไม่ไหวไม่โอเค 2,000 บาทใช่
ค่ะนัแหละอืนั่นแหละถ้านักเรียนมี
ประสบการณ์การตกเครื่องบินตกรถไฟตกอะไร
อีกตกรถตกเรือนักเรียนก็คอมเมนต์ไว้ได้
เลยนะตกรถตกเรือก็คอมเมนต์มาบอกครูฟ้ากับ
ครูเรียมได้เลยใช่ค่ะส่วนวันนี้หมดเวลา
แล้วใช่แล้วค่ะต้องลาไปก่อนแล้วไปก่อนนะ
คะนักเรียนแล้วเจอกันใหม่วีีดีโอ
หน้าได้เลยค่ะสวัสดีค่ะค่ะบ๊ายบายบ๊าย
บาย